we're asking every Canadian to purchase
this t-shirt in as you can see it's
orange
that's rice pitch to bring back boring
in other words get life back to normal
promoting these simple black and white
tees to help support Canada's health
care industry 100% of the proceeds of
this shirt are gonna go to buying PPE to
frontline personnel and our most
vulnerable communities now I know that's
not an exciting prospect or point but
the faster we get those guys protected
the faster they get us back to boring
this shirt is so unremarkable that it
actually renders its wearer completely
invisible
for instance I'm I'm quarantine with my
mother-in-law and she's been looking for
me for days yeah Ryan continues to use
his fame to help others during the
pandemic he and his wife Blake Lively
have already donated 1 million dollars
to food banks Canada and feeding America
and for Ryan's latest virtual visit to
Sick Kids Hospital in Toronto he teamed
up with Maple Leafs player austin
matthews they're doing good all while
sporting matching Christmas sweaters I'm
sure these are gonna be the next big
thing like everybody's gonna want one of
these sweaters I think so too I see a
redesign of the the Leafs uniforms for
the 2021 season